对传统诗词应有的了解与欣赏
这个很重要
有没有觉得说哦
原来歌词创作班除了歌词的教学之外
还可以学习到不同领域的美学
或是不同领域的一种知识
我觉得这样子才是全方位的吸收
而不是单单只有歌词的部分
今天要跟大家补充的养分是传统食指
当初我在写中国风歌词的时候
很多媒体记者问我
那你平常看些什么书呢
我都跟他们讲
我常常大量的阅读宋词
因为宋词是流行歌词里面的一种直接的养分
它本身就带有曲的格式跟节奏感
所以呢对于歌词创作的这门课
我们一定要去认识传统古诗词
所有的传统古诗词是从诗经楚辞
汉赋
唐诗
宋词以及元曲
这2000多年来一脉相承的古诗词文化
这些古诗词文化它有一定的创作规范跟格式
而这个规范跟格式呢通常都体现在韵脚的使用
跟平仄与对仗
这样子的创作条件
相对于小说跟散文而言
这些古诗词就被统称为韵文
就是韵脚的韵韵文这样子的一个创作的约束
对我来讲产生了一个很奇妙的变化
怎么说呢
创作上有个约束不是坏事
因为真正有文字能力的人
他可以把约束当做一种必要的条件
就像我们当初写歌词一样
旋律已经在那里了
还有还有关键字
还有呼应的主题
但是我们一样交出我们教得出手的一个创作
那时候我就跟呃媒体记者分享
通常我创作歌词的时候
我都是站在对方的一个需求去想象
因为最后传唱的人是他使用的是他
而不是站在自己的角度
所以通常需要修改
我都会尽量的配合修改好
那我们话题回到传统诗词
这些传统诗词因为有一个创作的约束跟规范
反而像古诗词产生了一个很奇幻的氛围
古诗词是一个仪式感很高的文字创作
因为它必须兼具了很多的条件
而这些条件也让它产生了不同形式的美
文字结构对仗的格式美
还有音律平仄使用的韵脚美
以及在这些规范下
文字的阅读跟行进间所产生的节奏美
这些古诗词是我们继承而来的文化财富
也是一项很尊贵的文化资产
更是我们持作者创作上的一个养分
来源传统的领域里面有取之不尽的宝藏
等待我们去发掘
除了古诗词之外
还有书法
书法的领域
我非常的着迷
为什么呢
书法是一种书写的艺术形式
而这种书写的艺术形式
全世界只有我们独有
因为它是把一个民族的文字变成艺术的表现
那除非你是这个民族的使用者
这个文字是你常常用的母语
否则你很难欣赏所谓的篆隶楷行草的美
譬如说可能一开始哦是甲骨文
这还是殷商时期青铜器里面的经文
然后还有秦篆
秦朝的篆书
汉朝的隶书
然后在唐楷
唐代的楷书
还有宋代的行书
这些不同的写法
丰富了书法这个领域的表现方式
而且他表现的方式很特别
的是说欣赏一幅书法
你可以欣赏他的笔墨美
浓淡干湿枯的笔墨美
另外你可以欣赏他的线条美线条
他的中锋
他的侧风怎么使用
另外呢布局美书法写在一张宣纸上
它的浓淡远近
他有个布局美
就说这边几个字用墨比较浓比较大
它通常下面的字就会比较幽默
比较轻
比较淡
比较小
去对应它
有些美感是对应出来的
所以书法的领域太迷人了
除了墨色美
线条美
布局美
还有留白美
有些人写书法就特地的这个字跟这个字不等距
他留一个区块
因为像印刷的书籍一样
有天地留白一样
他留下一个空间
让你这个布局的质数的结构布局不会失衡
但是又有看直玩位这个想象空间在那里
所以书法艺术很迷人
是它有各种不同欣赏的角度
而这样子的艺术的领域呢
却只有使用汉字的
我们才能是直接看懂听懂
因为一般外国人
他可能最多只能把书法当做一个线条去欣赏
可以再来书法有相呼应的很多艺术的表现形式
譬如说草书
草书基本上它就是抽象主义
草书又分狂草
金草跟章草
狂草
那个基本上他就是一个很潇洒的抽象主义了
然后隶书隶书很平稳
他力求字句的平衡感匀称
对仗美
隶书的欣赏的美可能对应工笔画
就是绘画里面的领域叫工笔画
还有魏碑
魏碑很粗犷
他是在岩石上把字开凿出来
雕琢出来
所以他有粗矿美
有一种粗糙
里面又带细节的美
还有篆刻
篆刻就是用印的印章篆刻
有时候你是欣赏他的文字的线条
还有布局哦
它的线条是有布局的
你你去欣赏这种
这种只有本民族才能领略的艺术美
我觉得这个是很珍贵的事物
因为其他国家或其他民族
除非你先学会中文
譬如山雨欲来风满楼
他楼可能用楷书
因为楼比较具象
还是建筑物嘛
然后风他可能用草书比较抽象
山雨欲来风满楼
先懂文字的意义之后
你再欣赏他文字所书写出来的书法
那个领略的美是更一层
那你不懂中文
你就看他线条而已
你不懂说为什么这个字写的像建筑物
为什么这个字写的像一阵风
为什么这个字写的像雨
比较动词
这个字写的比较像名词
比较固定在那里
你除非你先学会中文
否则书法的美你可能打折扣了
你可能就是看到他的布局线条而已
所以呢传统的养分不是只有古诗词
书法也是
而且书法的美对我来讲
他是要钻研好几年
你才能领略
因为他的线条
他的笔锋
他的墨色
他的布局他都有一定程度的要求
这样子的学习是无止境的
那我觉得说甚至于乐学都应该开一门书法课程
找一些老师来传授
让大家领略欣赏书法的美
节奏美
他就是文字行进间的一个顿点
它会产生一个阅读上的一个规律
譬如说可能李清照的如梦
令昨夜雨疏风骤浓
睡不消残酒
却道海棠依旧
知否知否
应是绿肥红瘦
还有个节奏感
纵使没有音乐
这个就是节奏美
很特别的节奏美
再是韵脚美
韵脚美就是可能押韵的那个韵脚
这个韵脚比较好解释
就是说古诗词一般都会用韵
那我们举个大家都知道的
床前明月光
疑是地上霜
举头望明月
低头思故乡
124用韵啊
第三枚哦
但反而很美
你全部都用
就好像卡死了
这个就是韵脚美
所以我觉得古诗词的那种美的形态非常的多元
像刚刚分享的传统美
除了古诗词之外
还有书法这样子的一个传统的养分
是取之不尽的
可能像我们有时候去一些古建筑
你会看到牌坊或者是说对联或是识字字
通常你有心思去了解这个状况的时候
你会发现说哎
我们中华文化里面的区块很讲究秩序
什么秩序呢
建筑物一定有个中轴线
天方地圆
石狮子一定是一对门旁边的春联
他就是一对左右相呼应
有个对仗美
西方的歌德式教堂追求是垂直美
它的尖塔都往上发展
垂直美
那你不觉得这世界很有趣吗
不同民族的美学会反映在它的建筑上
传统建筑是城市的文化名片
每个民族对于美的价值观
对于美的要求不一样
所以所有盖出来的建筑物的房子都长得不一样
那多有趣啊
我去日本看到京都的美
当然京都的美是仿唐式的建筑
那这也很好啊
日本请整个城市的力量
把你的唐代完全的封锁在那里
像时空胶囊一样
你就不用穿梭时空了
谁也回不去唐代嘛
但是你花机票一趟去奈良跟京都
你就基本上看到唐代的七成了嘛
这不是很好的一件事情嘛
就是说这样子的美充斥在各个领域
所以呢我们回过头来写歌词的时候
你就要有个空间的营造
通常我写歌词的时候
前面会去布局空间跟结构
副歌的时候会去经营情绪跟情感
这样子的话有个对仗
很多的美都是对比出来的
一定有东方的美才对比出西方的新天鹅堡
很特别
如果全世界只有一个民族
一种文化没得对比了
那你你哥德寺教堂怎么知道还有徽派建筑
东方还有徽派建筑
还有合掌村
你你看不到的嘛
没有对比的美
让你去对比欣赏了
但是我们都看得到
所以我觉得说现代人很幸福
你可以尽情的去拥有这些美
再把这些美化成你的创作的养分
那我觉得说最适合经营的文字美
以歌词来讲
其实是中国风的歌词
因为中国风的歌词不那么的浅显
不那么的白话
它可以适度的去经营文字的美感
譬如说可能帘外芭蕉惹骤雨
门环惹铜绿
而我路过那江南小镇
仍
惹得你这个就很有画面感
你写这样子就是很太矫情了
现在流行歌词可能是都会霓虹灯咖啡馆
或者是说一些情绪的用语
什么离开落泪纷飞
然后心碎
像这样子的一个画面感
你不能出现在中国风的歌词里面吗
所以我觉得说创作上的很多元
也是很幸福的事情
你可能有比较浓烈的情感哦
用这样子类别去发表
比较偏古典中国风的
用这样的类别去发表
所以呢各位同学
我刚刚是有透露出一点讯息的人
那个将在下堂课跟下下堂课跟大家分享
坐实所有相关的技巧跟方法